reconfirme rare qu'on finira pas voilà
la question qui est sur toutes les
lèvres depuis janvier dernier citons
craignent un art confinement nationale
après les fêtes de fin d'année
finalement jean castex avait indiqué
qu'il préférait éviter cette solution
avec le président de la république nous
avons souhaité le mois dernier nous
donner tous les moyens d'éviter un
nouveau confinement et face à la montée
de la transmission de la copie 19 et de
ces variants le gouvernement a
finalement pris la décision de
recombiner localement certaines régions
comme à dunkerque dans les alpes
maritimes le confinement le week-end est
une mesure lourde
aujourd'hui ce sont vingt départements
qui sont sous surveillance accrue pour
le gouvernement ces départements
pourrait faire l'objet de mesures plus
drastiques si le couvre-feu ne portait
pas ses fruits un couvre-feu au sujet
duquel gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement a indiqué qu'il faudrait
tenir encore quatre à six semaines
certains préconisent une solution à
mi-chemin en or confinant que le samedi
et le dimanche
alors doit-on re confiner le week-end
doit-on tenait le week-end on a tous les
chroniqueurs va surtout alors quel point
car t on à maître fabrice di vizio merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes venu avec un
dossier hausse a prouvé sa jolie et
jimmy mohamed merci d'être là - jimmy ça
va être compliqué mais je sais que vous
avez des arts et aux styles différents
alors vous vous pensez qu'ils vont
continuer le week end et me alors
malheureusement je pense qu'on ne va pas
confiné c'est ce que les informations en
train de ça il est important c'est ce
que france info vient de bandes annonces
et il n'y aurait pas d'enseignements en
ile de france
advienne que pourra ou à vivre comme ça
alors c'est qu'il ya plein de gens qui
disent vaut mieux mettre tout le monde
dehors que dedans
est ce que vous avez entendu cette
histoire ne l'en qui disent on est moins
il ya moins de contamination dehors
c'est à dire si on laisse tout le monde
dehors sûr que quand on confie mme
méjean évidemment et c'est un scandale
de voir des policiers à 18h15 mettre des
gens justement à la maison leur disant
mais rentrez chez vous partez alors
effectivement il est une règle à 18
heures vers il faudrait que les pauvres
il ya la règle et la façon d'appliquer
la règle je pense que lorsqu'il fait
beau et qu'on a eu aucun divertissement
depuis plusieurs semaines voire
plusieurs mois qui a deux trois rayons
soleil et que les parisiens décident de
sortir sur les quais de seine puisque
faut pas oublier paris c'est pas au
disney il ya quelques endroits
simplement on peut éventuellement
profiter d'un peuple et d'un espace
moment là il y avait possibilité de
laisser les gens un peu tranquille moi
je préfère des gens dehors même un peu
collet que dans des appartements alors
on va voir
oui oui quoi qu'est-ce qu'il a changé là
dessus ou alors est-ce que vous avez
utilisé pas ça
non je pense que malheureusement il faut
consulter non à l'extérieur où vous avez
évidemment je préfère voir les genres
dehors qu'à l'intérieur
évidemment si vous êtes face à face que
vous buvez un peu d'alcool que les la
distance se réduit oui vous pouvez
potentiellement de tomber malade or on
sait que le virus se transmet sous forme
d'aérosols c'est dans les lieux clos
sans masque où on tombe malade sur les
quais de seine le risque est proche de
zéro c'est à dire qu'il est égal à zéro
mais il est proche de zéro donc moi je
préfère les gens dehors que à
l'intérieur ou dans la chicha comme dit
non a priori il y aura pas de rebond
heureusement que c'est sans dénoncer
alors par contre s'est entraîné beaucoup
de confusion on donne des seuils d'alert
et carla trop jaune toutes les couleurs
on est au seuil d alerte maximale
malgré ça on prend aucune mesure
supplémentaire dans ces cas-là on arrête
les seuils qu'on arrête de dire aux gens
il ya 20 départements où c'est la
catastrophe puisque l'on ne met pas de
mesures supplémentaires
et pourquoi l'île de france n'aurait pas
des restrictions plus strictes alors que
à nice ont fait un confinement à voir si
elle donc pourquoi il ya cette
désorganisation et qu'on arrête les
points presse tous les jeudis en dix ans
la situation est catastrophique
on va attendre 15 jours rendez-vous dans
quinze jours disons les choses
clairement
advienne que pourra on se voit dans
quatre semaines book 3 km y verrons s'il
faudrait être confiné pour que les
choses s'arrêtent parce que là pour
l'instant le gouvernement dit que dans
quatre à six semaines ça va s'améliorer
alors que ça s'améliore il ya trois
possibilités la première c'est le
confinement ses serveurs leur fiche de
gaza est un deuxième chose c'est la
vaccination massive
rapide comme en angleterre comme en
israël sauf que ça en prend pas le
chemin et la troisième c'est celle qu'on
a décidé d'utiliser ce et prendrait des
du joug mandji les lancers et cela a
voilà c'est ce qui se passe oh non pas
tant de faire un pari absolument
incroyable de se dire que dans 4
semaines ça va s'améliorer un peu
article c'est quoi et c'est quoi cette
histoire
1 et est ce que pense tout et été des
acteurs comme moi c'est quoi cette
histoire de secte dont quatre semaines
on a l'impression que c'est la
libération
alors j'ai interrogé tourne autour de
moi personne ne sait d'où ça sort c'est
comme ça ça sort de là rien paris on
peut comprendre jean ya peut-être un peu
de bluff n'en faut qu'on donne un peu de
perspectives aux gens parce que bluff on
pète les plombs et d'ailleurs à ce
moment là il ya un mois je pense qu'on
était tous prêts à subir un confinement
strict pendant un certain temps c'est
que maintenant que là on n'est même plus
est prêt à accepter le confinement du
week-end je pense qu'on a basculé
puisque il ya un mois on nous disait que
c'était la catastrophe
on n'a pas confiné là nous dit que c'est
la catastrophe mais ça fait six mois que
c'est la catastrophe les
en scène ne serait pas prêt à accepter
une mesure de restriction supplémentaire
maintenant on peut espérer pour le mois
d'avril peut-être un peu de beau temps
on sait qui est un peu de saisonnalité
du virus sur la peut-être réduire la
transmission va être un peu plus à
l'extérieur donc les soldes bottes en
quoi un peu dix minutes et collective un
peu de vaccination et puis un peu de
chance le pari des mêmes macron j'espère
que ça marchera parce que encore une
fois on a l'impression que les docteurs
sont contents du confinement non moi ça
me saoule et j'espère que dans quatre à
six semaines
on vivra un peu mieux et pour l'instant
je suis un peu sceptique alors qui dit
oui qui doivent après division vous
dites quoi vous non non moi je dis hou
là c'est bien d'être pour ou contre mais
sur quoi vous fondez comment ça commence
comme ça commente est ce que finalement
donc on reste dans le domaine de
l'opinion tout le monde s'en fout d'être
finie en com de la miette d'ailleurs
parlé donc proposé une mesure de lutte
contre une épidémie sur quel fondement
alors on va faire le point sur quel
fondement il ya une vacation la russie
nouvelle ambiance
alors qu'ils menaient d'ailleurs très
très que recherchent pas beaucoup
d'annoncés prêt devait tourner ma
fenêtre en fait honnêtement non samedi
vite ses attendus
je pense à se mettre d'accord on va se
mettre d'accord on va éviter ça on va
tout de suite effectivement mis du sien
et on a évité
j'ai esquivé les questions les questions
sont des vraies questions et fiat ont
des vraies réponses
moi je suis là pour être éclairé par
vous donc vous proposer une mesure
j'aimerais bien savoir sur quel
fondement voilà tout il a dit alors
qu'ils étaient plus claires la 10ème et
brûlant en coulisses que sato parce que
là je vois pas un spoiler venir je sais
ce qui nous a fait très simple dont
l'époux est très simple honnêtement
quand je dessine moi je cherche pas à
débattre avec vous et cherche pas à vous
convaincre si vous cherchez nommé mais
vous à dire mais quelque chose mais
c'est ça qui compte jamais sur ce
plateau décidément même n'est pas plus
important vous avez désormais cécile et
peut-être que solution est là non non
non non
violent non mais moi je viens débattre
précisément mais pas pour effectivement
débattre pour débattre on n'est pas là
pour ça on est là pour éclairer les gens
qui nous regardent ce combat est donc
terrible
vous dites que de confinement ma vous
êtes favorable au confinement vous en
avez parfaitement le droit mais je
présume qu en tant que médecin c'est pas
juste une opinion en l'air et que donc
vous avez des éléments qui fondent le
raisonnement je cherche juste à les
comprendre c'est tout pour freiner
l'épidémie le confinement est la mesure
la plus efficace vous le dites sur quel
fondement s'est passé partout dans le
monde les pays qui ont confiné sas et
d'observation des hommes comme
l'angleterre bien sûr et annonça marche
pas pour l'angleterre
l'angleterre ça ça vient d'enchaîner sa
marque pas mais je vous dis non vous ne
dites oui premier pourquoi ça marche pas
ça ne marche pas pas ces questions et
réponses à saint-preuil vous demandez
une question il aurait les yeux
maintenant on va demander plata gilles
verdez gilles verdez oui m division
bonjour avait amené votre petit dossier
traditionnels je voulais y ait des
études
les voilà notamment rigoler non mais je
vais bien du monde entier je veux bien
vous étudiez mis à part mais allez-y de
bien aux études il n'ya que d'autres
recourent aux autres allez-y je vous en
filmant l'eau et calédonie mois de
neurospin mois rue des elmes appartient
en propre
voici sa réponse et du bleu qui ont
financé mon ca membres gaz et les études
alors je disais les mêmes qui valent ce
qu'ils valent qui sont soumis au débat
mais vous faites la semaine dernière des
fous sur ce point mais ya rien eu mais
monsieur oui je cherchais pas à faire de
la sophistique avec moi ça marche pas
oui te dire vous proposer des études
dans notre grand classeur alesi je vous
en prie
sortez les 6000 n'a pas dansé orthez
l'élan monsieur ça c'est effectivement
vous et des études je souhaite les
connaître après ce que les français
peuvent connaître les études le monsieur
à l'origine malaisie il n'ya pas votre
truc déjà cible
si vous voulez moi 10 en six journées à
certains membres comme les études sont
toujours contradictoires il ya bien sûr
mais ça c'est ça les amuse ou bien c'est
un bon débat et c'est intéressant
finalement mais moi j'aimerais bien voir
nos éléments alors est-ce que vous
pouvez ouvrir ces deux éclairs et nous
déjà à l'oral non ça marche pas ça des
gens savent à quel moment tap
en fait la seule victime dans son cahier
voulait pas se remettre et je ne suis
pas dernière ma vie je viendrai moi mais
j'aime comprendre quelque chose c'est
que monsieur est un homme de spectacle
oui mais rien d'autre en fait mais alors
que moi je considère que les spectacles
sont donnés pinana traders il fait pas
des spectacles à cissé dit la vérité
allez-y je vous entraîner je ne peux pas
révéler sa vraie danse boursiers aux
études et me dit quand vous pensez bien
entendu pas j'essaye il n'y a pas ce que
vous pensez vous sont fous monsieur
césar mais il a fait ce qu'il a fait ce
qu'il a dû riom skate dont je sens que
les tendances il n'y a pas d'autre
solution
j'ai étudié tout ce que disent les
préfectures du nord d insécurité
thurnheer pas dormi ou d'adressé le feu
dire alors laissé l'enquêté il n'y a pas
d'autre solution
hélas qu'un confinement le week-end à
parce que la semaine dernière vous avez
réservé sur la confinement le monsieur
di vizio d'études confinement non à vous
qui ne fréquentaient pas les gens
réalisent ils n'auraient pas les gens
filment le maintiennent en a pas on n'a
aucun élément et ans est reçue par n'a
aucun élément on a des éléments ce
confinement en tant que tel ce week-end
on débat comme mesure ou pas mais ça
m'intéresse de brou qu'il fréquentait
pas les gens la semaine dernière j'étais
samedi à paris sur les champs elysées
monsieur pourquoi nous refusé de montrer
le cadavre de dossiers mais je n'ai pas
à obéir si vous avez se divise sur ces
boues qui nous donnent des ordres ici
c'est mon mano cyril hanouna est
essentielle
voilà monsieur c'est indigne et c'est le
mérite mieux
sané avec nokia numéro de clown nikos
non j'ai une question vraiment
s'effectue à travers des questions mon
avis oui je suis pas le confinement mais
on a l'exemple du nord pas de calais
aujourd'hui on sait que le taux maximum
qu'on peut atteindre par exemple au
niveau national c'est 250 cas pour
100000 habitants
ok on est déjà à 3 122 cas pour 100000
habitants ce qui est énorme et on voit
en nord pas de calais ce qui s'est passé
ce week-end aujourd'hui on est à 600 cas
par 100 mille habitants donc ça n'est
plus aujourd'hui c'est un seuil qui
n'est même plus tolérable en et au delà
de ça ce sont les soignants les aides
soignants qui parle parce qu'ils sont
dépassés oui il faut quand même savoir
que les lits d'hôpitaux occupé par le
cos ville aujourd'hui c'est 72%
donc ça veut dire qu'on des programmes
on commence à des programmes et des
chirurgiens important vous pouvez me
confirmer
monsieur jim et moi même on est en train
de déprogrammer énormément de cas
important donc mais quel est votre
solution parce que je vous entends mais
là en l'occurrence le quart du
nord-pas-de-calais
c'est un cas qui existent mais le
week-end dernier qu'est ce qui se passe
on parle du masque je termine juste le
tuer le masque est obligatoire
là bas dans le nord pas de calais dans
les marchés aux abords des écoles
mais pas obligatoires dans les rues
passantes et les rues commerçantes donc
est-ce que ça n'est pas l'explication du
triplement de cas à barjols week-end je
vais vous résumer question moi j'y vois
tout le monsieur est un adepte le cadre
de l'académie de médecine
il a sorti un avis non mais c'est
intéressant parce que non monsieur
non mais pas mais répondez moi j'en
appelle justement parlant je ne réponds
l'à propos du masque vais vous répondre
jacques monsieur est un adepte des cas d
une médecine skov ce qui est dommage
c'est qu'il prend l'avis du mois d'août
sans prendre en compte effectivement la
vie su ma vie suivant qui est du mois
d'octobre où l'académie de médecine dit
que le masque en lieu clos a une
importance ou en cas de rassemblements
importants en extérieur c'est l'avis du
haut conseil de santé publique par
ailleurs et là dessus c'est un élément
clair ce que dit monsieur jean yves
ramette est intéressant c'est à dire que
a aujourd'hui un élément c'est que c'est
pas ces deux c'est dehors que
effectivement on peut réussir à régler
ce problème de manière avec laquelle
avec le climat où tout ce qu'on veut
mais c'est certainement en extérieur que
les français que les gens sont le moins
en danger par rapport à l'intérieur est
ce que vous savez quels sont les
endroits où l'on se contaminent en
france
et non à la maison c'est pas moi qui
joue non c'est vous le savez la banque
axel est effectivement de l'institut
pasteur qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut mais
qui vous montrent qu'en réalité maceo
alors ça c'est intéressant mais l'atout
résignation ces maladies allez-y c'est
le lieu de contamination dit l'étude
et bien cassé je l'aï envoyé ces lots
fois nié que c'est là-bas extrêmement
important effectivement une diminution
du risque d'être infecté notamment en
faisant du sport à l'extérieur
non c'est intéressant je verse et c'est
pas moins ses instituts pasteur qui le
dit je ne me trompe
absolument pas l'étude mais rien de fait
est que le premier au delà des
restaurants etc sur lesquels il ya un
débat mais incontestablement le premier
lieu c'est bien celle-là fier la récente
1,7 et une astucieuse et du mois de
novembre il avait lu par exemple on a
quand même des exemples aujourd'hui des
exemples de quoi mais c'est la terrine
là on a des exemples
répondez moi monsieur répondez-moi les
excès de question on a un carnet mai
dernier le coin car je sais chose
d'assez incroyable c'est moins de
connaissances sur un sujet plus on a de
conviction mais ça va venir à bout
n'empêche si vous avez un petit côté dia
furieux c'est en fait de malades
imaginaires lundi cette économie la
parole et je veux dire si vous commencez
par la victime
attendez vous à ce que je vous réponde à
ses principes du contradictoire monsieur
w
vous savez une ravi d'avoir un peu
d'audience ici c'est vous ferez vous
fait plaisir à ce que la lumière du
plateau vous montrer que je devais
beaucoup plus calme en coulisses que sur
le plateau et le sud voici monsieur vous
porterez de sketches ici alors que on
oublie tout simplement que vivre avec le
virus en ce moment et bien c'est mourir
avec le virus lorsque vous parlons des
condamnations vous dites les comptines
m'annoncer la voix quand par monsieur
c'est qu'il ya un problème vous et moi
j'ai parlé non attendez vous parlez vous
n'avez aucun élément depuis tout à
l'heure sinon effectivement de dire ce
que vous pensez
moi je ne pense rien j'ai ce privilège
ne rien penser j'attends effectivement
vous me disiez que l'institut pasteur a
tort là vous avez raison ou l atout
alors quand même
question j'ai une question quand même 2
millions de téléspectateurs hier soir
qui nous ont regardés et je pose une
vraie question donc vous dit toujours
qu'on n'est pas factuel là je suis
factuel et personne ne me répond c'est à
dire il ya des gens qui s'opposent quand
même cette question et essaye de
comprendre à l'extérieur non c'est vrai
le port de battement avait repiqué
visant à dépasser dans le pas de calais
ce week-end mais je pense qu'il ya plein
de choses qu'on ne comprend pas
honnêtement on est vraiment dire il faut
dire la reine et la réalité
ouais nettement je pense qu'on pensait
réellement si on suit les modélisations
quand on écoute skis en bois de janvier
que là on serait dans la panade absolue
et que ce serait la fin des haricots
c'est ce qu'a pensé tous et finalement
le virus nous réservent de nouvelles
surprises et je pense qu'il faut être un
peu humble avec ce virus et qu'il faut
arrêter d'être très sûr de soi et de se
dire voilà comment ça va se passer alors
d'un côté on a un devoir d'information
d'expliquer que peut-être on a ce risque
là et on espère qu'il n'arrivera pas
mais effectivement il ya de la confusion
en janvier on pensait que ce serait pire
eh bien ça ne l'est pas la seule chose
qui dramatise c'est que le monde entier
tous les gouvernements ont du mal à
gérer cette crise honnêtement c'est
difficile on tape beaucoup sur le
gouvernement mais je pense qu'on
n'aurait pas forcément mieux à leur
place il faut être honnête les décisions
à prendre sont extrêmement difficiles
il ya qu'à faut qu'on c'est assez facile
mais on a un épidémiologiste un
virologue de re monsieur prenez la place
de l'immigration et la clause que je
veux dire mais monsieur vous ne propose
d'abord la main sur monsieur vous
proposer pour cible parce que je suis
vraiment jamais à la bic avance de vous
c'est que moi je propose rien c'est vous
qui avez des solutions
moi je me contente effectivement de vous
faire part de celles que vous ne
connaissez manifestement pas qui sont
celles de la communauté scientifique qui
si vous passez ya peu moins de temps ce
plateau télé vous auriez peut-être le
temps de les lire les études premiers
éléments deuxième élément celle des
autorités sanitaires internationales à
propos desquels je semble je crois
savoir que vous les ignorez également si
vous me poseriez pas la question de
savoir ce que je propose est enfin en
troisième lieu celles effectivement que
commande le bon sens des
épidémiologistes dont vous vous réclamez
par ailleurs ce qui m'étonne si vous
voulez monsieur léo probablement jamais
à l'abri c'est intéressant ce que dit
jean et mohamed
oui mes petits papiers alors monsieur me
poser des questions qu'est ce que c'est
que le coc vip rêve
est ce que vous savez juste pour savoir
c'est quoi le convier prévu commis près
de côme i prev vous êtes généralisée que
j'allais forcément ce que vous proposez
de mesures de confinement vous
et donc que mes petits papiers comme
vous dites et bien c'est pas moi qui les
ai écrits donc je présume que puisque je
suis épidémiologistes tandis que vous
non vous avez effectivement cette
qualité d'avoir lu ce qu'est sorti donc
locaux qui prennent vous devez
effectivement savoir quand vous proposer
le confinement ce cas locaux vip rêve
oui ou non c'est le cas tu sais quoi
c'est quoi la quoi vous jouez en fait là
bas je vous pose une question aux yeux
j'ai pas envie malgré ces bons dire que
j'ai pas été démis le gist et qu'au fond
à ce titre je n'aurai pas droit au débat
mais ce que je note c'est que quand nous
restons dans le factuel précisément bas
je vous pose une question toc médecin
parce que vous êtes médecin et qu'a
priori aux qualités de médecin d'autres
paroles semblent avoir une autorité plus
importante que la mienne
et bien dès lors je vous pose la
question savez vous de quelques vip
raide comme un pas en avant qui
répondait on passe à la dernière partie
alors c'est quoi le convie brève
eh bien non c'est une question que je
pose à neutre mais c'est quoi on n'a pas
réalisé
c'est simple en fait c'est une enquête
qui est faite par santé publique france
à poursuivre le comportement de la santé
mentale pendant l'épidémie de comics 19
à sa porte et on y apprend des choses
intéressantes dans ce ca pour sa part
dont 12,1 pour ça s'apprécie non mais ça
mais en fait cela laisse à désirer
problème c'est que vous n'avez aucun
argument monsieur vous attaquez à titre
personnel mais essayons nous restait si
vous voulez bien sur le domaine de qui
nous intéresse et évitons de glisser sur
le personnel comme vous l'avez fait à
benicio essayons si vous voulez bien de
rester sur ce qui nous intéresse et sur
les données objectives points qui loupe
ap
manifestement vous pose débat je vous
pose la question vous proposer le
confinement vous avez parfaitement le
droit monsieur mais d'abord ma question
sur lequel fondement n'a pas reçu de
réponse
mais ensuite sur l'évaluation bénéfices
risques est ce que vous avez une idée de
quel est le risque du confinement et de
l'eau que nous en sommes sur la santé
mentale précisément des français
aujourd'hui est ce que vous le savez
castaldi est juste heureux
non mais c'est le procès que vous avez
effectivement beaucoup de dents quête de
papier effectivement et dès qu'on vous
pose une question vous vous botter en
touche et vous sentez vous sentez vous
vos enquêtes
j'ai effectivement que comme tout le
monde j'ai un peu suivi depuis
maintenant une merde noire
j'ai un peu celui tout ce qui entre dans
le monde effectivement la seule chose
qu'il semble freiner je lis pas arrêté
mais freiner l'épidémie
c'est le confinement leur comprends
qu'il y ait des conséquences dramatiques
aussi bien économiques que
belgique et emmental mais au poupon peut
pas sans cesse de l'arrivée des papilles
dire voilà il ya six assayas y est
détaillé pas solution mais au bout d'un
moment c'est très fatigant parce que
vous vous dites voilà voilà ce qu'il
faut et quand on vous demande qu'est ce
qu'on fait à moi je ne suis pas là pour
ça non c'est pas là pour ça non c'est
parce que je ne suis pas là pour ça
parce que j'ai dit merci mais est ce que
vous imaginez
est ce que vous imaginez si moi
j'arrivais sur un plateau en vous disant
voilà la solution
non vous n'êtes pas symbolique vous
dites vous voilà voilà qu'elle est déjà
riche jeune montagne en l'état moi je
suis riche de la connaissance des autres
c'est peut-être effectivement ce qui me
différencie de beaucoup de médecins mais
nous on était et moi j'ai pas de
doctorat en médecine et donc à ce titre
je n'ai pas l'universalité de la
connaissance mais cependant il ya quand
même deux points
est ce que vous savez ce qui s'est passé
docteur mohamed en 2014
c'est la richesse du débat est ce que
vous savez ce qui s'est passé au sierra
leone en 2014 oui moi et ses passes avec
des volailles ebola et de la contrée de
la sierra leone a lutté contre ebola
justement on ne sait pas on ne sait pas
si ils ont lu pendant cinq jours ils ont
confiné et vous savez ce qu'a dit msf en
partie médecins sans frontières et par
ailleurs l'om et a dit c'est pas la
solution
elle il faut pas faire ça à ne surtout
pas faire ça parce que ça ne sert à rien
de mélanger des malades et des bien
portants premiers éléments dont msf
c'est un gars chaud française quand même
un deuxième élément
effectivement on a dit attention parce
que sur le plan des libertés publiques
c'est très très grave il faut pas faire
ça alors que alors que le pays envisage
est quelque chose de tout à fait
extraordinaire c'est de tracer les
malades d'envoyer des brigades
sanitaires pour aller tracer les malades
est mêlé sort samedi
ouais quand même monsieur s'il vous
plaît vous nous parlez d'un virus vont
parler d'eux et vos lames est nouveau on
vous parle d'un autre virus un virus que
le monde entier ne connaît pas et vous
vous êtes rendu faire des comparaisons
comme si vous tombez seul je ne sais
quoi parce que vos lobes dire il se
donne pour comparer les pitbulls à vous
le connaissez maintenant mais vous vous
connaissez beau la maison
là on parle d'un virus mondial
personne ne connaît à part macron s'il
allait voir le voyant ce qui est des
solutions mais n'a malheureusement
personne n'a la solution que ce soit
macron que ce soit la solution parce que
le virer sont pas très mais qu'il n'est
pas prévisible
il n'est pas imprévisible auprès des
gens parce que il n'est pas le même à
chaque personne chaque personne réagit
différemment
et en plus de ça on en train de se
manger des variants vous voyez très bien
qu'il n'ya pas de solution que nous
qu'est ce que vous cherchez vous
chercher à attirer des gens qui
pourraient avoir des solutions et non
madame je cherche effectivement à
montrer non ce que je cherche des boules
dire ce que cherche la nomination répond
si vous me le plaisir est pour nous
poser la question ce que cherche aux
mondiaux pas grand-chose france je
cherche non mais pas grand chose moi
j'ai l'humilité effectivement de poser
des questions parce qu'il me semble que
c'est de cette façon que la démocratie
se constituer en parti questions qu'ils
sont sur les rangs mais non c'est là
vous vous trompez c'est que les réponses
je les ai pas mais d'autres que moi ont
proposé des solutions salle oms en
particulier qu'a dit tester tracé sur
toujours souhaité avec fabrice a aussi
dit que l'hydraulique laurent qui ne
marchait pas et je crois que c est lors
d'épreuves ça ou des formulations
prenait l'eau et mes seins sont pas des
musiques nomades dans le connu merci la
machine j'aurais pas merci de parler les
occidentaux rockin parce que monsieur
est un fervent partisan de you and i 10
qui aurait dit que l'hydroxyde rocking
avait fait 200 millions de morts il a
cité sur votre plateau d'on ou deux cent
mille mots sur votre plateau donc c'est
un fervent défenseur de l'udinese quand
ça les arrange m'éloigne 10 avec
d'autres ont également signé un papier
extrêmement intéressant dans lequel ils
disent que le confinement n'a apporté
absolument rien mais bien sûr là ça ne
vaut plus rien mais quand monsieur
années d'histoire de la chloroquine
quand l'om est ce par le bachelor ou
steam ça vaut quelque chose mais quand
on parle de confinement ça ne vaut plus
rien ceci dit autre chose
la déclaration du great barrington je
sais bien les gens qui nous connaissent
rien
le groupe harrington c'est les meilleurs
épidémiologistes au monde qui
effectivement se sont réunis pour dix
des six ont proposé une solution
alternative au confinement et toutes ces
choses et
ça passe évidemment par le traçage ça
passe par des horaires différencié pour
isoler les personnes fragiles
ça passe par un auto confinement des
personnes fragiles à propos duquel
d'ailleurs je note présidents des
conseils scientifiques lui même l'a
également préconisé donc quand vous
venez préconisé le confinement comme
seule solution messieurs dames
je me permets de vous dire que vous avez
contre vous l'avez la communauté
scientifique de plus en plus unanimes
sur le plan international et que c'est
pour ça que monsieur mohamed a pas été
capable de citer les études sur
lesquelles ils s'appuient parce qu'en
réalité dit on n'a pas le premier menace
si vous voulez alors moi je veux bien
qu'effectivement ça soit moi contre le
reste du monde mais moi je ne représente
personne d'autre n'avait que ce que les
autres que les gentils géants sont
franchement
chaque semaine vous arrivez vous révisez
quelque chose là vous avez révisé ball a
annoncé le début nous débiter bola moi
je vous respecte infiniment mais je vous
le dis franchement vous nous saoulez
parce que vous arrivez avec des trucs
vous êtes content contre tout autre
jimmy contrôles montrent tout le monde
du tout mais s'il veut détrôner y aurait
du tout votre post il a une autre
postulat c'est d'être contre caen de
tout ce qui se fait et non mais ce que
vous auriez la science infuse mais non
vous seriez contre sassou est monté à
chaque fois et c'est vrai vous êtes
contre tout ce qui ce fait vous ne
proposez rien
il ya des gens une image quoi répondait
pas le drame c'est quand un ancien
rédacteur en chef du parisien est
capable effectivement de proposer des
solutions à une épidémie et me demanda
un avocat de le faire et quand ce
dernier s'appuie pour ouvrir un débat
avec un éminent scientifique en face de
lui sur les études favori effectivement
on lui répondait vous proposez rien mais
je voudrais juste savoir mais les pso
l'excellent pro bass il a été sympa mais
je n'ai aucun problème est que
j'ignorais pourquoi j'en aurai un ya un
débat d'idées et c'est là dessus c'est
intéressant je regrette plus d'avoir été
acquis à titre personnel par lyon mais
bien un débat dit rien d'autre
wen après on ne peut pas confiné alors
on va voir ce qu'on pense c'était des
spectateurs tiens oui à 25% 3,70 à ce
que dirait bien sujet mille mois
maintenant j'avais les gens ils étaient
prêts à un gros confinement là il ya
encore un mois et l'a terminée mais pas
la salopette à te dire autre chose
toujours pas compris l'intérêt du
confinement parce que personne n'a su en
expliquer la débandade les mobilités
j'aimais confinement a germé non mais
vous dire on se pose la question sur le
confinement pas on est déjà confiné on
va travailler on rendra au résultat
rentrer à la maison à savoir être pas de
cinéma pas de spectacle divertissement
de la division on est déjà confiner la
seule chose c'est qu'on pourrait dire
que là on a à peu près de 1500 morts par
semaine
est ce que ce sera acceptable si on
profitait de la vie je pense qu'on peut
rendre a pu poser le débat si on allait
au restaurant
si on profitait peut-être qu'on sera en
mesure de se dire bon bah ya des gens
qui meurent c'est pas très grave sauf
que là il ya des morts alors que on ne
fait rien de notre vie et ça fait plus
de quatre mois que les lieux de culture
sont fermés et que les restes en débat
qui chante ou on en a on en a marre en
fait on voit ça te sens que dj hero est
ce que j'aurais fait qu'il pose une
question on se contaminent dans les
restos s efforçant d accord sur ce point
on sait qu'au cabinet à tous les nains
consensus sur ce point face aux
contamines dans tous les lieux clos et
ne masque en fait principalement d'un
restaurant mais comment vous expliquer
c'est une vraie question qui a réagi ce
qu est une ville dans la ville
eh bien les restaurants soit ouvert
depuis mois de décembre et calais qu'on
n'est pas un seul cluster comment vous
expliquer je termine par vos gueules
dans les restaurants d'entreprise on
n'est pas un seul kloster comment vous
l'expliquez alors si ce n'est de
relooker bonnes questions m e division
oui mais sauf que c'est une plateforme
des changes et que quand vous arrivez à
rungis
vous repartez et donc vous allez dans
les quatre coins de la france donc vous
n'avez pas de clusters concentré comme
vous pouvez en avoir dans des écoles
n'ont donc c'est facile de dire qu à
rungis en a pas deux clusters non
monsieur est donc alors derrière ce que
vous dit non
l'arganier c'est quoi ces ouvrons les
bars et les restos n'ont ainsi pas de
dire que les premiers mineurs c'est
qu'effectivement vous renverser la
charge de la preuve c'est vous qui
préconisé des mesures pour lutter contre
le coc binamé voulu style et les et
faire c'est de montrer qu'elle marche
jeudi pour réagir vous avez tort
monsieur ce sont les salariés de rungis
ce ne sont pas les gens qui vont quatre
coins de la france et les restaurants
d'entreprise monsieur c'est aussi des
restaurants de l'allaitement les
restaurants d'entreprise on tombe malade
c'est des lieux on transmet le virus
vous avez des éléments associés mais
l'école lorsque vous avez pas réciter
l'étude la cie du pasteur qui dit qu'on
se contaminent dans les foyers mais
avant de se contaminer dans le foyer où
est-ce qu'on se comprenne une réelle par
le lieu de travail lambon levé son
masque lorsqu'on va faire une pause et
on va retirer son masque
lorsqu on va faire la fête c'est place
en face aux crises en famille et donc
après on ramène le virus à la maison
j'ai vu une personne
sa pose et le coût final des médailles
ksar termine avec ça j'ai vu une
personne cette semaine qui à 67 ans
quelques midi une dame et elle avait dix
jours de fièvre jeudi mais m
est ce qu'il ya d'autres personnes
malades chez vous et me dit oui j'ai mon
fils handicapé qui est aussi le co vide
ou es ce que vous avez attrapé le virus
c'est mon mari qui l'a eu j mais où
est-ce qu'il est votre mari mon mari les
morts étaient à la morgue et j'ai pas pu
aller le voir ça fait dix jours elle
même gelé hospitalisés et ils sont
tombés malades de quelqu'un qui les a
rendu visite car il ne portait pas le
masque sur un lieu où il l'a déjeuner
donc à partir de ce moment là vous
pouvez dire et monsieur moules et les
conséquences de votre parole sont et moi
j'ai une dame 55 jours dont l'esprit
d'ailleurs si vous voulez tenter de dire
merci
gimme gimme alors qu'est ce qui va se
dire demain juste absolument rien en
fait tant qu'homme comme chaque semaine
on va on va dire qu'on va attendre la
semaine prochaine et que peut-être la
semaine prochaine la semaine prochaine
donc voilà on attend et on espère que la
vaccination va s'accélérer et encore une
fois il ya astrazeneca j'aimerais dire
juste aux gens on a parlé des soignants
mais pour la population générale
astrazeneca est un bon vaccin s'il est
un peu moins efficace il est toujours
plus efficace que celui de la grippe
et si jamais vous faites locaux vides
avec astrazeneca peut-être que vous
l'aurez mais offrez une forme légère
vous ne mourrez pas et vous n'irez pas
en réanimation
donc ces deux données extrêmement
important car il ya une défiance
vis-à-vis de ce vaccin est plutôt on
sera vacciné mieux on sortira de la
crise et donc le vaccin qu'il vous faut
c'est celui qui est disponible
aujourd'hui
n'attendez pas fighter dans trois mois
six mois un an il sera peut-être aller
maintenant